kamala harris
came out
she compared
the capital riot last year to
not just
pearl harbor but september 11th as well
good morning
certain dates echo throughout history
including dates that instantly
remind all who have lived through them
where they were
and what they were doing
when our democracy came under assault
dates that occupy
not only a place on our calendars
but a place
in our collective memory
december 7th 1941
september 11
2001
and january 6
2021
on that day
i was not only vice president-elect
i was also a united states senator
this comparison
is deeply offensive you know some of us
knew people who died on september 11th
okay some it wasn't that long ago a lot
of people remembered especially people
around new york especially those who are
millennials or older might remember this
to compare 3 000 americans being killed
in a terrorist attack to the horn guy
dancing around the capitol rotunda is
really disgusting and is genuinely
extremely offensive but it's got a point
it's got a political point
january 6th
is a myth it is
completely made up if if not completely
made up it's 99 made up it's based on an
actual riot that took place at the
capitol but virtually everything you've
been told about it is a lie and has been
turned
proven to be a lie and even some
newspapers had to retract it though no
one was paying any attention to the
retraction so the lies persist
all countries have myths how was rome
founded
rome you know rome the roman republic
becomes the roman empire how was it
founded
there are two stories about how rome was
founded
one is that it was founded by aeneas
right like the aeneid
like the the
poem by virgil it was founded after the
trojan war and the other is romulus and
remus and these are related myths but it
was founded by romulus and remus these
two boys who were who were fed and
raised by a she-wolf and then they they
form the civilization and romulus kills
remus i'm simplifying a little bit but
those are the stories did that happen in
real life ah probably not
but that's the myth and the myth is the
identity of rome
it's much more important than whatever
council met and wrote some document
together and took the many many steps
that very slowly created what became
wrong
no romulus and remus that matters a
whole lot more
nash even even modern countries like our
own country have national myths and some
are true and some are not true
george washington what's his
relationship to a cherry tree every
schoolboy knows this or at least used to
know this when we taught the american
myth that george washington chopped down
a cherry tree but he could not tell a
lie so he admitted that he chopped down
the cherry tree did this happen no but
it's part of the myth of america and it
and it forms a lot of our identity and
it forms our understanding of our past
and our forebears and who we are
ourselves january 6th
with all the scare music and all the
hyperventilating and all the pearl
clutching that is now
part of the american myth the democrats
are desperate to establish that one and
so they're going to have festivals every
year and they're going to have big
speeches and they're going to have
big solemn celebrations they're probably
going to erect a statue they're going to
have broadway performers do songs and
dances to it lies shape history
just as much as the truth very often do
you have an account with coinbase are
you thinking of opening one are you
crypto curious
i am i hadn't really been that
interested in crypto and then recently
i've just completely gotten into it with
the nfts and the the ethereum and the
meme coins and all this stuff well
crypto may very well represent the
future of money it's certainly a very
important new technology and so
everyone's really getting involved and
they're getting investing in it and
trading it and like so many things in
life there's a smart way to do it and a
dumb way to do it the really smart way
to do it is to go check out alto ira so
that you can invest in bitcoin ethereum
cardano in a tax advantaged ira super
easy to set up you can invest with as
little as 10 bucks no setup charges this
is industry leading security
the advanced encryption standard for
wallets and private keys multiple ways
to fund your account you do it with cash
cash contribution transfer cash from an
existing ira roll over an old 401k are
you ready to take your investments to
the next level diversify like the pros
and trade without tax headaches open an
alto crypto ira with as little as 10
bucks go to altoira.com michael that's
a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com
m-i-c-h-a-e-l start investing in crypto
today alto ira.com michael i'm so glad
that you liked that clip it's great it's
wonderful to have you to be with you to
welcome you into my
private study in my head it feels very
intimate if you want to keep up that
intimacy
ring the bell subscribe then you'll get
notifications head on over to apple
podcast but if i stitch your google play
wherever you get your audio podcast type
in the michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you